- welcome Super Trouper army this is
your general foolish Maximus today we go
to war with along our side our comrade
Chris Delilah
that's right in the words of Oliver tree
also known as Chris D'Elia
yes known as Chris D'Elia but for Oliver
tree Chris de la creme of mine with that
ultimate death yeah yeah that is the
ultimate diss for me that it really is
thank you to our sponsors ring and me
undies now Chris is a hilarious comedian
I'm sure you guys all know him friend of
the show this is his third time being on
come on tickets he's on tour Chris
D'Elia dot-com slash tour he's got a new
Netflix special coming out that he's
recording on the 9th follow the leader
of the month of November neither
November 9th of some undescribed month
second season of you on Netflix is
coming up soon you're starring in action
movies was that snider it's all
happening or Chris D'Elia it's a good
time to be Chris D'Elia yeah yeah yeah
yeah it feels good I'm going to
Albuquerque to do I don't even know do
you know so all right so do you know
about the stuff with Albuquerque that
happened with me you had beef oh yeah I
mean yeah you don't know so all right so
you're trash-talking all I'm a talented
boy yeah I was just being silly but so I
just wrote on on Twitter something like
Albuquerque makes Jacksonville seem like
paradise or something or Narnia and it's
not good I don't even well yeah it's
amazing right all the talking animals so
I did so I wrote that on Twitter and
then the next day I was in the news in
Albuquerque
they were like comedian bashes
Albuquerque and then they interview
people on the street and they're like
yeah I don't know why he'd say that I'm
like you don't so then on my podcast
congratulations I talked about it huh me
the news was just hilarious to me I mean
it was so funny to me and then I made
another segment on the news later it was
like he talked about it on his podcast
and the Despero man helped and I was
like you I'm talking about how shitty
the city is you're proving it yeah I'm
the headline like that nothing's
happening and so when I got this Zack
Snyder movie army of the Dead which is
you know I've my fans know you know I
don't think it's out there in the world
but my real fans know I've I want to do
action I tell my ages are like dude a
lot of these comedies that you put me
out for like you know I bet the best
version of comedy for me is gonna be my
stand-up you know like dude let me do
some something give me the gun or
something so they finally got this thing
and and I and I I never liked and I was
like it takes place in Vegas I was like
dude I get to go to Vegas for like two
months and just kind of like develop a
drug addiction or like you know and
something fun and and they were like no
shoots in Albuquerque not like are you
[ __ ] I mean I I'm sure I mean people
on the street in LA will be like hey
what's up with Albuquerque I'm sure in
Albuquerque it's more of a thing it was
on the [ __ ] news you are like a
household name there yeah an Albuquerque
that's New Mexico yeah that's like a
little in the cuts people get a little
weird and wild out there dude I was
there last week to do the fitting and
everything and all that and meet all the
guys and [ __ ] and I walked down to the
hotel lobby and I was like hey where can
I get something to eat
and they're like no and I was like what
they were like it's just there's nothing
closed and I'm like it's like a 10:30
you know and now it's go back up the
hotel so I let me check Yelp you know
and so I check Yelp and there's a place
open I was like okay I called you guys
still serving yet till 1:00 so I was all
right cool so I go down I get an uber I
go down to the hotel lobby and I was
like hey mmm just asking you because I
don't know this area really I'm going to
this spot whatever it was is it safe I
don't know is it a bad neighborhood and
the guy in the lobby goes like this ah
no it's it's a perfect it's fine I was
like okay cool just check it I've known
I did I told the story of my pockets
ready but so so I was like okay cool and
so I get in the uber the uber driver
says hey are you Kristalina and I was
like yep and I use like how cool I was
like ah nice you know and then he's like
I was like he's like you know I don't
normally do a goober driving I just I do
it at night but in a day time a crime
scene investigator yeah and in my head I
I immediately think well no you're not
that's a high it's not like yeah you're
not a brain sir you know talking about
brain surgery money but you got it made
like a degli money yeah yeah so I'm like
all right yeah so I was like so I'm
going to this spot he's I got the spot
in the thing okay cool and then he's
like man it's crazy seven people were
shot here last week he's like I worked
the case not like the guy just [ __ ]
said it was a fine neighborhood seven
people got shot that's a real [ __ ]
story did you check the crime report no
I was like you know and how was the food
it was fine it was tacos it was fine it
should have been you know honestly maybe
should've been better because it's like
a Mexico taco okay so that's the trick
about New Mexico I don't think they're I
think you want Old Mexico for the video
I know it's a bunch of white people I
know yeah I'm problem yeah I mean
they're yeah yeah yeah a lot a lot a lot
of I don't I don't know man we'll see
I'm gonna be there for two [ __ ]
months
it leads did you got some great stories
man I think there's gonna be some beef I
think you have to lay low a little bit
yeah well you should stoke the flames
while you're there too well I'm here and
you're here [ __ ] come fine I mean
knowing me yeah yeah you know I'll do
something like I wanna I thought about
but is there something funny I could
shoot there or whatever because you
don't like the mayor yeah so I'm gonna
you know fly product the producers out
there and you would dare I got to do it
you know why not keep up to date mm-hmm
so you totally moved
for two months right yes yeah I mean I
keep saying like are there spots where I
can come back and forth and like we
don't know the whole schedule mm-hmm I
get it it's a big production yeah dude
that's that is super exciting I read
this obnoxious girl and it sounds like
so much fun
yeah it's a zombie quarantine yeah in
Vegas and I'll tell you what I like that
because whenever there's zombie movies
they take over the whole planet it's
like how pathetic are we as human beings
they quarantine reyga's great that means
that's I like that okay you guys go into
the quarantine on a heist yeah I don't
know how much I can say so you say that
what I read someplace yeah but and I'm
like man that sounds like a lot of fun
Zack Snyder who's up like made so many
incredible films I mean I am super
excited yeah yeah yeah I mean I you know
I just wanted to do action that's what I
wanted to do that's what I want to do I
want to continue to do that I'll call me
just straight action I mean you want to
be you want to be an action star yeah
100 you want to be what about it this
was John Reeves
those guys are mine like Keanu Reeves
yeah just cuz you can go from Bill and
Ted do you know John Webb yeah
even like Nicolas Cage I love those kind
of [ __ ] movies where he's just like
you know like like face off like those
movies like no good you seen face off
you know it's you know it's like it's so
good let me tell you the plot yeah a
superstar cop and one of the most
notorious criminals in the world I don't
remember why this happened but their
faces get transplanted why on earth
would that happen there's no legitimate
reason but their faces get transplanted
so the criminal goes and sleeps with the
cops wife yeah and the cop thing with
his homies face off literally
metaphorically oh man it's like it was a
Michael Bay Michael Bell oh that makes
sense it's gotta be a Michael Bay right
it's John Woo jeonbu directed yep that's
a wolf li okay
it's too complex for bit oh I'm thinking
about what's the one where the yeah
what's the prison where they go to
prison the
yes that's me the rock I think that's
highbrow birthday
that's the babe made the Ross yes but
face off is a man that movies good
that's right because face off had the
white the doves that Flynn the change on
boys were had with the doves and like
they go all the way like the criminal
goes and [ __ ] his wife you know with
his face on and [ __ ] and you get she's
like hella into it like he doesn't she
doesn't realize that his whole body's
different yeah really
buddy's yeah oh yeah their bodies
different right what just face or body
off but he [ __ ] a different body yeah
yeah no I well that if you those kinds
of movies yeah hell yeah and I think
it's because in my head like when I was
like younger and I thought about it I
was like how cool would it be to do
stand-up comedy but also like imagine if
[ __ ] Jason Statham did stand-up
comedy like the contract it would make
no sense
it would make [ __ ] zero sense that
was what I want to do you're conquering
to the left and right yeah and I don't
want to be like I'm not talking about
action movie like what's that one with
Mark Wahlberg and nobody comedies yeah
yeah I'm not talking about I'm talking
about taxes hanging yeah the end of it
that's what a helicopter and so I
started working out hard you know and I
was like I was I hate to my agents I was
like dude I'm not good I'm not gonna not
get action because of me bro mmm-hmm I'm
doing all I can
so I got [ __ ] a little bit more beefy
you know and then they were like alright
you know and then so the beef help do
you think the beef got you there I don't
know how did they end up like shirtless
pics uh they had taken pictures of your
new naked I mean you've been yeah I mean
I always post I always have always
posted with my shirt off because I think
it's funny but you know now that right
I've been working out a little bit more
people like oh your pose was assured I
was like dude I always [ __ ] do it
yeah yeah that's true it doesn't change
the context when you get jacked yeah
yeah
what am i off hey you know that's funny
in a sense when you get jacked you got
to start like wearing your shirt mark to
know people like oh what you bought you
yeah yeah but it's funny so I don't know
I just want to [ __ ] run around with a
gun because it was so who's your idea of
the favorite act of the perfect action
stars a kyon oh yeah uh-huh is my
favorite because he's like I really like
Bruce Willis too but he's kind of as
much as I think Tom Cruise is such a
ding-dong
he's so good though he's a great [ __ ]
actor yeah he really is I mean people
just hate on him because he's the big it
was the biggest what it maybe still is
you know but he's well yeah that too
because he's a psycho yeah but but every
movie is so good
yeah what look that's what the think the
thing about Keano is like he's been
famous as long as anybody really has
been famous right and I always think
like if you've if you've been famous for
that long you you have to be crazy
everyone is always just like like mega
famous yeah a list for 30 years there he
is
I know and so with Tom Cruise it's like
people say he's crazy
yeah but I get it he's knows an Cruise
forever it's not your goal I would be
I'm I'm already feeling you know a
[ __ ] deal is like are you looking to
join Scientology in 10 years I am [ __ ]
all that I'm looking at creative one I
mean yeah Tom you gotta outshine time in
the crate Tom and the crazy yeah mom I
want to be the baby ala l ron hubbard
guy yeah cuz tom is like best friend
with the main guy you want to replace
them and I'm the main guy yeah
yeah I'll get other guys coming up all
like I'm like it's like those guys who
go to high school and watch the
basketball players like that's what I'm
doing a younger acting oh my god yeah
he's got some talent right I need that
Tom Cruise right you know I could see it
I feel like you can I think you I think
I'm just trying to get a cult man for
real
fantastic well your future's looking
bright and I can see you're a little
more unhinged than the last year
so that's why do get more comfortable
with you guys for yeah yeah let me
speaking of getting comfortable let me
show you this video and you just don't
know what you think I love watching
videos and problem because they're super
nice super need use so called
attacks progress is absolutely and you
know as acceleration it's not the
problem which I can I can it's all with
the little mites command but mmm bike
acronyms difficulty both see that the
probe is silly picked up on Titan
murmurs Oh curse me there's a better
than that silly but are we in see a
doctor employ means to me Korea yes use
up your second sign is isn't often
homies now so can I go see a lawyer but
Ottoman and play up I see a nice return
you're gonna probably that's the boxes
on bail sooo I mean you probably
survived but that I said no two seconds
on the clock you almost made it
what oh wow that's hard to do
dude he had three seconds on the clock
bro he almost made it that huge show a
countdown to see how long you can go
without open your mouth
welcome to not draw it up you see we can
go one minute without the grown open
your mouth we've got the most nervous
guys in the planet
you know what it looks like the whole
time it looks like he is so it looks
like this guy is the real looks like
he's the first guy that can actually
like turn into a werewolf and it's like
he's like it happened like three times
before I've had the serum and like I
don't have it on me
and he's trying so hard he said it's my
body I know that I cannot turn into it
if I just calm down but the clock is
[ __ ] with him he's like why is this
clock even on this and he's like almost
there and then after it cuts after he
almost after this that was like he got
it he just swallowed it he's like okay
I'll be human I love that he soldiered
through that and I would like to have
seen her face
yeah that's true that's a good point but
what does it count down for I saw what I
think it is is it's like a political
show you know where they're like it's a
hot take all right I give him three
minutes okay like there's the beginning
yeah we've got four minutes it's a hot
oh it's four whole minutes and the
[ __ ] almost made it he's like
just don't feel it's just zombies may
make a good politician because he's
willing to make the difficult choice oh
yeah you know they man and condemn sure
dude I'll tell you what if that was I
would have meat all over myself
yeah I would have picked on it would
have made it to her yeah it uh III
wouldn't even a try would have just been
like that is really uh Wow so is he like
a viral sensation now I think he's the
president now I think he's the president
of Finland yeah Wow that's hilarious how
many views Wow that's a classic bloody
look it was a full mouth oh my goodness
oh my I think he's got some kind of
genetic thing because he looks like he's
halfway to Stephen Hawking
maybe I bet he was so nervous yeah but
he was nervous like I saw in the reddit
comments that
apparently the see that's not funny
though before that he's got a problem
yes yeah on it I mean can it be funny
theater problem it's less funny it's
less fun yeah I wish he was just a
regular guy yeah what up for that cuz
then it's like cuz then you can identify
with it too because like I'm a regular
guy alright
and I will be so funny if that happened
to me congratulations on on getting
fifty thousand uncanny highest cameo
remember in fact I've got the link here
yeah I have to tell you you know you can
book me for fifty thousand dollars
I was I was kind of upset because I've
been I've been [ __ ] around with cameo
and I goof on kami a lot and when I saw
that I was a little bitter so I I would
ask them alright Sawyer because they
they probably do to you - they do -
everyone they email me and yellow like a
thousand times a week I talked about I'm
apart cuz they text me and [ __ ] they
text you oh that's cuz you signed up
yeah I signed up yeah what do they say
um hey you want to put your logo right
yeah you wanna Laurie right yeah because
I started it I was like well I I think I
started for $1,000 that's the max and I
didn't know it was the Matt or maybe I
did I remember because I and so I was
like I'm not doing this [ __ ] for less
than $1,000 and I started getting booked
like like eight nine times really yeah
yeah you do him so I did one and then I
just felt weird it's that I just was
like I'm not gonna do him anymore and
then I would get booked and they were
like and by the way I didn't know that
they make 25% of it mm-hmm then I was
like also I'm only making 750 not only
but and then I was like and then I was
and then it kept being like you got
booked it's gonna expire and I was like
yeah and I just felt I felt I felt like
I'm well first of all I'm not gonna do
it for $30 because it's just not worth
it for me well yeah but then $4,000 then
I feel bad yeah yeah charging people
that so so so I was like I just didn't
do him and then I was like it sucks I
can't make it more and I did it on my
podcast and some of the people on cameo
list of my podcast cuz they they talked
to me about it
and and then somebody wrote me and said
hey we put it to $50,000 for you and I
was like what and I'm now it won't go
bad if somebody gets that I won't feel
bad because you have a lot of money
you're getting that so there are no
bookings well that's what I like being
on there
but as you said put to Moe's ridiculous
and I don't want to take $1,000 for ya
fans to be like hey hey while I'm taking
a dump be like hey guys yeah
congratulations
I just don't get I was looking at this
on my podcast I don't get why people
like I know these people make money okay
so I wanted to look over this with you
because you bring that up yeah but at
any rate um I was like give me a hundred
thousand I'll sign up for cameo right
any SEC done that yeah the intern he's
like done and then I signed up and he's
like sorry my boss says I can't give you
a hundred no no no that will delete my
[ __ ] account yeah I got I guess yeah
yeah but let's let's start from the top
Caitlyn Jenner is the I guess the number
one real right 2500 she she lint
she lists her icon or her her occupation
is icon sure what else does she
I do accept chill I don't know she's a
show right it's very self completa
wonder if she wrote that about I want to
change mine to Lord but like Caitlyn
Jenner is rich oh yeah that's all Kevin
O'Leary the Kevin O'Leary
he literally is a billionaire whoa he's
a sharda part of me was like maybe maybe
they're doing it because it's like
fanservice but what a Vance service for
$1,000 do it for free man yes exactly so
what I'm saying maybe they thought maybe
they thought I spent time thing about
this maybe they thought that it was
making them more famous to just beyond
like it was a brand thing you know I'm
saying that's the only thing that makes
sense to me
no and it's like oh you'll have to have
an Instagram maybe they are thing all
you have to have a cameo I mean because
I'm amazed at the breadth of people
Brett
the guy makes money broke Chris Harrison
I've been watching my Bassam [ __ ] oh did
he create don't wonderful he hosts
millionaire he's on bass okay but he
pops you watch bachelor not he pops in
for two seconds is the dumbest ready
yeah he's rich he'd the dudes on TV
going down let's see
but like Carrie page I can't get over
this hi hi imagine her in her $500 in
her fifty million dollar mansion hi it's
Caitlyn Jenner it'd be kind of but
that's the thing though like you'll be
kind of crazy to get one from her like
whoa like but these are girly cuz she's
probably just watching TV with the sound
on you know what I mean like dude these
guys Charlie Sheen bro like let's look
up some net worths well he might have
went bankrupt but by the way is making
money like Helen mr. wonderful net worth
you know it was that 400 million don't
know like what's going on here really
Caitlyn Jenner are these guys just
natural-born hustlers you know what I
mean maybe 100 million
this guy's like dude I'm not gonna
decline the opportunity to make a
thousand rounds yeah that's how he is
yeah surprise Bill Gates isn't on here
Billy Zane when the [ __ ] lost some
heard that name that gotta be 500 he's
gonna yeah he's gotta have money though
no go down keep going down I don't know
if Billy Zane super rich Billy Zane net
worth
Alaska my summon was in [ __ ] Zorro
dude about 20 million nah he's you think
that's generous yeah I think that's
generous till it was in Titanic but but
minor role yeah what we got here again
this is another shark bro Robert yeah
what is this the most expensive why am I
not up to [ __ ] time I want to say you
got blue bald you're not number one
yeah they don't they're [ __ ] with me
they excluded you they just want to get
your ass down how many orders you get it
just zero I definitely have zero Gary
Busey that would that one would be worth
the iced tea iced tea come on he's been
in [ __ ] SVU for 334 watches 3,018 20
Tommy Lee look at this homey from the
office look at that but there's a guy
who probably you know yeah that's a that
one's worth so it's Terrell Owens I bet
that guy
I [ __ ] doesn't he didn't he squander
all his money like I don't I don't
really know actually another honor bar
balls yeah see that some of them make
sense oh the [ __ ] guy yeah that makes
sense
who's Beth she's a shark too and she's
also on the Desperate Housewives there
you know what I'm noticing my desperate
but the Housewives of Beverly Hills it's
pretty you've been watching you know all
the Sharks up here I wonder if they have
some kind of deal with cameo
I mean Brett Favre dude Brett Farr some
row what are you doing I mean it's it's
I love looking through this list this
shit's making me want to up my price
trip Oh Donald you got Trisha Paytas god
bless normies her norm baby he's got to
get paid I don't think I think norm got
shafted I don't think he's rich nor
makes good money doing stand-up though
for sure does he sell big audiences I
mean big enough to where you're making
definitely my point five million you
probably also not it probably also gets
odd gigs where it's like oh they're big
fans they want to fly without you and
$200,000 and this is when it starts
getting weird when you got the Billy
Baldwin yeah yeah yeah this is when it
starts getting you got me oh I want to
get Neil I told them I told people I'm
Park as I get neo to say you've got
Lance Bass here yeah you know this homie
you got Colton it was the bachelor last
season okay you've got Kevin from the
office but the Colton was a good guy to
have it Riley because what the [ __ ] is
he gonna do that guy's broke write a
book yeah that's not gonna get braver
anyway you get the idea but there's some
really funny ones you can really oh look
at this you got the tick this is
incredible her eye concert with her Ted
out from the office well a lot of office
people huh
yeah they're all up here too man Ernie
Hudson chocolate dough Robert Robert
toffee Wow it'd be pretty cool there's
people I get it it's really the ones I
don't billionaires billionaires yeah but
it's it's a weird bear there's the
perfect guy to get on it right here Oh
Chumlee the guy from Ponce
bro obviously has no butt Oh yo Chumley
is the richest dude from that show how
he made some kind of company that went
mega Craig oh really oh I'm wrong 5
million well are you pretty good I mean
it's pretty good huh well yeah I thought
he was richer it does say is there a
girl here wrote Chumley is richer than
what you think
yeah show's been on for a bit right yeah
yeah for some reason we still always
watch that in Israel yeah never I was at
helix parents house you know it was
always on yeah I don't know what kind of
crazy anyway there you have yeah but I
wanted to tip I want to let you know the
Cameo people are not respecting your
well your pay yeah I doubt even if they
were I would he ever get booked for
$50,000 you should book yourself just to
all but then I'd have to give them so if
you if anyone's listening from cameo I
would sign up for a hundred thousand and
I I would if you asked me to do one I'll
do it and I've been for $50,000 and I
will take your money
yeah like straight up and buy cool [ __ ]
for me mm-hmm you know I'll give a
little to charity I guess you know
because that would probably right these
are you donate to charity um I do like a
benefits and [ __ ] doing stand-up that
had announced yeah should I do [ __ ] like
that I do want to I do want to start
something though I've been thinking
about a lot lately like I want to start
some kind of foundation or something you
know oh that seems like a whole night I
I know that's the getting like dude I'm
I'm like I don't want to do more work
but then like really a foundation what
would you add or I don't know see it's
more work for you I know I what are you
got to pay someone a management all
[ __ ] and I don't I don't have I'm not
like I don't have like I don't I always
think of like people who do that like
[ __ ] super-rich Bill Gates
yeah like I don't have obviously that
kind of money yeah I'm doing well but
like you know it's like I think it's
because it doesn't require so much right
yeah and you don't want to mess with out
you don't want to do it wrong yeah so
you have to have someone legit yeah
yeah I would just donate to like st.
Jude's or something kids we yeah sir
yeah yeah yeah yeah that because that's
just yeah but I I do want to do
something like that though eventually
well if you can one day have you know
Tom Cruise money Tom Cruise net oh yeah
yeah and you you know I don't know how
570 million bro Tom Cruise yeah [ __ ]
hell bro just an actor but how much do
you money do you want
how much do I want yeah in life yeah
like a fall so if I reach this number
I'd be like I'm done right making money
yeah I think the number for me would be
see people are gonna think like dude
you're so [ __ ] out of it yeah but who
cares well what do they know wearing
Gucci slides probably 20 million yeah
well I always thought like that is like
because then you can do whatever you
want
I'm never restricted by money if you ask
the normal person no they'd say that I
think a normal person would say lower
because they don't understand how much
it cost to live the lifestyle that I
enjoy right
but if aunt Dan Dan and Zach how much
money would you need to be like I'm done
working if you could ignore this
conversation well not do you want you
don't need to worry about money over
again you can do whatever you want life
yeah I would I would say something lower
I probably just say like a million bucks
and you don't understand see ya a
million I'm not gonna go out and buy
gucci slides yeah but doesn't thing if
you had a Milosz you would buy that
again okay
is any in but that's what I thought I
think plebs like Dan would say one or
five million I think that would be
called debt let me tell you million bull
a million but you're gonna be back to go
back to work in two years absolutely set
the bar higher but also keep in mind
we're talking about living in LA which
is yeah but that's the world you got it
you gotta have enough money to live
anywhere that's the data that's true if
you want to have a nice house part of
family that's a question that's what uh
in LA how much well in LA it's at least
a million is a [ __ ] to be on so
family so seriously
in LA it's true this I think if you want
a nice house a nice single-family house
in LA it's like 1.5 yeah one starts at
one point from yeah so if you want to
live a life where you can drop whatever
your fridge all your not working you can
go wherever you want whenever you want
you first clock in about first class you
want to go on a trip till done you want
to go on a trip to Fiji you want to go
on a trip whatever die nanny [ __ ] is 20
30 grand you want to go to our first
class to Singapore that's 20 grand yeah
yeah so so 20 grand has to mean nothing
to you exactly and if you're Amelia have
a million-dollar swing there's a lot of
money so if you have one email what's
your number for me to be like I did it
you're gonna it's gonna be really high
you have to be a hundred million dollars
and nobody's gonna still I would still
be like I could lose this yeah no you're
right though it would people don't
understand how that's possible but
they're not wearing cootchie slide yeah
and I must show shoes where you these
ones aren't aren't too too expensive
how much ordinary one retail 160 maybe
but did you buy everything
I don't even you got rocket yeah I don't
even remember I think I don't even
remember so if you bought a shoe for
$300 would that be would you consider
that expensive no yeah right but it is
yeah for sure yeah but that's the that's
see that's the difference Zaki nian
what's your number I think I got agree
with Chris hundred million [ __ ] just
something I like to call [ __ ] you money
because like you can that's just at a
level of beyond you know cuz okay so let
me ask a question who said 20 million or
who said 1 million is man yeah alright
well you know right now you're like yeah
actually like you're thinking I are
first ya gotta be like here's the thing
I maybe I didn't understand the question
correctly because you're saying just
instantly retire
I wouldn't retire with a million if I
had its money
I play the markets I would live and
press it's the means where I'm saying
the money to where you're like okay I'm
done
I don't have to do whatever I want any
time and I don't have to worry about
running ever I want any time yeah then
yeah I mean it would have to be higher
than that yeah what do you think about
like eyeing a house will ya you'd be
done if you spend and don't forget you
got to pay tax pop with you oh I don't
pay taxes well yeah well that's enough
it's a good is a very good well that is
a counterpoint if you spend fifty
thousand dollars a year which is easy to
do in LA that'll last you twenty years
Dan fifty and you'll be borough and $50
that's fifty so that's all good man
twenty years I said yeah exactly
I'm 32 but you probably didn't want to
spend more than that $50,000 a year in
LA yeah you could live comfortably off
that you could live you know yeah yeah
but Dan has a good mouth mates that's
what he's thinking are in this world
[ __ ] house man yes yeah your dreams
aren't even good right now that we have
a kid is a thousand a month
yes exactly diapers and what you're not
realize like five hundred and I know
what's right and you know how much money
it's like and like because I would still
do stand-up I would still do it but but
right now
I I have to do it because it's my life
it's my make money but like I would
still do it even if I had 100 million
dollars but I would be like yeah I don't
have to you know but then that's why you
stopped painting and you be kind of like
I love watercolors like well good that's
your true blessing in life like yeah
what the [ __ ] would what would you do
you had a hundred moon doll you keep
doing this Parker problem I mean what
else am I good yeah yeah it's kind of
like what else might be I'm gonna sit
home play video games for three days I'm
gonna get so depressed and bored
yeah there's no I well the work is the
work is the life yeah you you have this
motivation you're chasing you want to
get you want to make money you I paid
and so you have this dopamine level you
have this chemical drive you do it a
hundred percent so I think it's
important yeah
my work is the life like my dad is like
71 and he is like I retire like he's not
you know I mean he's going he's still
gone but like he's just like I don't get
it guys talk about retiring he's like I
just don't get it what are you gonna do
yeah he still he can [ __ ] bend down
touches tells you 70 but he's spry means
it's like yeah whenever we like do
nothing for a few days I get so I know
like oppress it's depressing
your body starts to hurt yeah you just
feel so like brain-dead I don't know
yeah and then you're like oh man if I
was retired I'll just go play disc golf
all the time and be so sweet you go play
disc golf watching it's [ __ ] sucks I
hate being here I know you know and your
free time is so much more fun like after
this podcast I'm gonna go home I'm gonna
watch TV I'm gonna cha it's gonna be
great yeah because you know you did
exactly that being said I realistic
number one hundred million is a little
[ __ ] high
but the prot thing is with twenty
million dollars but you could put that
in a money market yeah sure at
two-and-a-half 20 million you're making
what true I don't know looking what
what's the number for 45 right now both
telling you what brand of 20 million is
about a year we gotta take a break just
in it right okay that's good man yeah
that'll cover a couple of plane tickets
or however you [ __ ] your quality life
is yes eyeko yeah we'll be right back
we're gonna throw it to a break and then
maybe I'll finally get an answer from
Ian about what his cost his forty bucks
all right we'll be back all right ring
is a product that I fully endorse that I
am absolutely in love with and a product
that was on Shark Tank that all of the
members passed on and now the owner of
ring the guy who went in there and
pitched and got rejected is a shark
himself wow what a story
how did he become a shark he made one of
the best products ever made let me tell
you about ring first of all you got the
doorbell you replace your old shitty
doorbell with this high-tech slick stuff
it rings like a doorbell but it's got a
camera
a microphone and a sensor detector you
can calibrate talk to somebody who's
there get notifications when they show
up anything a package a surprise visitor
or planned visitor you can do it all on
your phone here's the best part let's
say there's someone there to break into
your house and they want to smash your
ring well that's too frickin bad because
it beams up it uploads the video
automatically as soon as it gets
detected and you will have it in the
cloud there there is no going around it
I have got ring floodlights all around
my house it is a ring of protection that
keeps me safe I've got these heat these
super powerful LED lights that blast
anybody that comes near by puts it up
dude I'm telling you if you care about
security if you want to know what's
going around your neighborhood and
around your house ring is the ultimate
product I love it thank you so much for
making this beautiful product and guys
as a listener you have a special offer
on a ring starter kit available right
now with a video doorbell and the motion
activated floodlight cam the starter kit
has everything you need to start
building a ring of security around your
home so just go to ring.com slash a tree
that's ring.com slash age 3
summer comes with a number of awesome
perks vacation Beach days barbecues but
here's the one that we could all go
without swampy dick swampy balls thighs
were the rub together crotch and Grendel
of chafing well we've got the solution
finally and here's the problem it's your
underwear because my undies has the
softest most luxurious underwear that's
gonna change the game forever it's gonna
keep your balls ventilated it's gonna
keep you fresh but it's gonna keep
everything going on down there just the
way it is you're gonna feel like this
mermaid your balls are gonna feel like
this Merdan maim under the sea under the
sea
I just got copyright clearing by Disney
let's talk comfort guys scientists spent
countless hours in the underwear lab
testing for the softest fabric than all
of the land what happens micro modal
which is a full three times softer than
boring old cotton not only that but you
can match your bottom half with the
better half and matching prints and
colors this is micro modal it's new
technology you guys cotton is ancient
technology the micro modal is the fabric
of the frickin future dude that's what
this shit's made out of you looking for
a hot new summer theme print well they
got a new one every Tuesday for frick
sake
Mandy's also makes the South disallows
pants in onesies you've ever felt
onesies I can't speak guys I'm on like
one hour sleep finally you can match
with your pup I'll finally you can match
with your pup with their new buddy bands
available in the same prints and colors
as their undies this what is button
buddy bands it's dog clothes okay you
can match with your buddy bands me on DS
offers Mandy's has a great offer for my
listeners for any first-time purchasers
when you purchase any me on these
products you get 15% off and free
shipping hold on back up 15% off
that's right 50% off a pair of the most
comfortable undies that you will ever
put on and your dick and balls would
never be swampy again that's my personal
guarantee to you not theirs that's fine
I and my back that with nothing to get
15% off your first pair of free shipping
and 100% satisfaction guaranteed I guess
that is their guarantee as well go to
Mandy's comm /h 3 that's me
Descamps /h 3
out we're back I want to clear the air a
little bit yeah people think me and Ian
are beefing but okay Ian just has a
problem with the microphone cuz he's
live switching so he's having a
difficulty getting to the mic I'm winded
cuz I ran two feet we got a run to the
bathroom here
so I just wanted out so in do we have
beef are you upset at me are you mad at
me people were specially rias I can't
stand this guy I'm kidding no beef
there's no beef you walk in here you
could tell immediately there's no beef
thank you you know rumors swirl around
the vegan office no yeah no you know
what I was thinking no what we were
talking about would you could you ever
be as a as a as a man like the guy who
just chills like a dad that just shows
at home like a stay-at-home dad
yeah and the man and the MA your wife I
thought kills it is kind of dreaming
about that it's always been my joy
because you just said but you just said
the work is the biggie right okay but
you have a job when you're stayed on
that yeah it's taking care of a kid like
we've got a one-month-old yeah mother
[ __ ] takes it so so you would have
work you know right you would have you
have gold yeah right okay so it's a goal
thing yeah all right cool yeah you have
like daily objectives right yeah
or weekly objectives thats what's
important I don't think I could ever do
that I could do it really I I could do
it big-time
what would be so great spent be at home
with it sure no you have it and you and
so you know what that looks like and
heels like and I don't so but I'm but of
course it's not for everyone
it is you [ __ ] piece of [ __ ] by
Nature
I put you're clearly you're but you're
not not that's not funny and like I
genuinely feel that I know I know I'll
tell you what you can do both that's the
interesting part yeah Ethan can be lazy
and like it can definite it doesn't have
that need to like oh I gotta get out of
bed at 10:00 a.m.
like no you'll just stay in the bed if
there's nothing so we have a lot
common that way because like I some days
like literally all I do is go to the gym
or and I don't even do you know bro
that's a lot yeah I get it a lot no
that's [ __ ] bad but whenever you have
to make a video and let's say there's a
deadline you'll work you'll stay up all
night if you need to all of sudden I'm I
wake up at 7:00 and you're not there
you're editing or I guess it's a problem
of motivation or you're just really
efficient you work when you know you
have to thank you really things about me
you're a procrastinator I think you try
to say in the kindest way well the thing
is you know if there's nothing to do I'm
really bad I guess at creating things
for to do for myself
mmm right look if I don't have a
deadline or something to work on I will
just veg out the gym are you [ __ ]
kidding I get it you don't worry later
no no it's not it's like the thought of
going to the gym will make just thinking
about it will make me exhausted for the
week yeah yeah okay
yeah so and I don't like it either I'll
veg out and I'll be depressed about it
but I don't have the will or the
motivation to go do anything but I feel
like for me even if I know that we have
nothing to do like I don't know if
something my parents put in my head but
it's like oh it's already like 10:00
a.m. I gotta get out of bed yeah I don't
have that no problem yeah I used to feel
bad sleeping but now that I'm a comedian
I work nights a lot I'm travelling all
the [ __ ] time once I I'll tell you
this man I hope this helps people out
there I would get sick if I get enough
sleep
I just straight up don't get sick hmm
like I I would wake up sometimes feel
bad I'd be like oh I got to get up
because I feel bad I sigh I I'm gonna
oversleep and I would just get sick
every now and then mm-hmm if I get and
I'm talking about nine hours of sleep
there's no [ __ ] way
there's no way I'll get sick mmm no way
and if I miss if I gotta get on an early
flight and I got to go to perform and
then I can't sleep with some water and
then I'll get sick sleep is the number
one thing for me it's well sleep is I
think we under values yes world
sleeping is good for everything by the
way your [ __ ] that we have to sleep
for so long it sucks we had JB different
brains I know but we got it bud bud do
we own but but it's like but ok and we
live a long life too compared to other
creatures on this planet but don't have
to sleep more dogs
I definitely got [ __ ] and they don't
even have big beautiful brains you know
what I'm saying well the thing is no the
shredder la Vella
the thing is dogs yeah dogs got [ __ ]
dogs got [ __ ] but they're just bored
by nature like what are they supposed to
do yeah yeah no well they were wolves
they were what I bet you wolves just
when they don't have to eat they just
shell they just [ __ ] chill Yeah right
yeah wolves are kind of like probably
they're kind of like us probably because
they're like but hey I'm real hungry
this is the dead laddie yes and I will
die you know what I mean yeah
but yes sleep is a powerful beautiful
thing I do think we undervalue it like
when you need sleep the most in your
life and you're a child mm-hmm and
school is so punk dude waking up at 5:00
a.m. as a kid and I've never had such
grueling hours of my life as when I was
a kid and like middle school high school
and it's waivable your for me it's way
easier wake up early now right like way
easier because you need you need sleep
more when you're overworked but I was
for real 14 I would have to wake up for
school every day I would be like how the
[ __ ] am I gonna do this how do people
wake up yeah and the truth is you don't
not know and now I can I get it it's
hard but it's like all right I got a
[ __ ] I gotta get on this flight I'm
will because you don't want to go to
school that's one and I do it too and
you're probably super underslept as a
kid you don't get enough [ __ ] sleep
when you need a limo
no [ __ ] way yeah if you want to watch
all the shows and eat a [ __ ] cupcake
and then you're gas twelve that's the
important relay for a kid yeah then you
got to wake up at [ __ ] six to go to
school you know yeah all my parents used
to [ __ ]
I let me tell you this dude never was I
ever late
one [ __ ] time for school never my
parents every [ __ ] time they woke me
up when I was in high school
wake up the alright yeah alright let me
just hold on
five minutes later wake up you're gonna
be late dude I'm not gonna be late I've
never been [ __ ] late I've never been
late maybe that's why you're gonna be
late dude my dad would come in with the
washcloth Lord on my face oh my god I've
never been [ __ ] late to school why
you treat me you know why like a [ __ ]
prisoner war because I think I'm gonna
do that because you're up and you're the
[ __ ] dad you're like my ass is up I'm
gonna make you hurt oh dude I'm never
gonna do that to my kids I wonder if we
could not do that because it what you're
saying is so smart like trust him it
wasn't late until now all right why
don't you say crazy I don't waterboard
wake up you yeah I know you're never
late so I know you're doing you know
what you're doing right right right
and I'll tell you what I'll tell you why
do it I don't know I tell you what banat
your kid later on is gonna be like look
what you said once my my my parent one
time out dude it used to drive me now is
to wake up think I usually got mad I'd
be like dick Oh [ __ ] think I'm gonna
be late I've never been late I've
should've never been late the carpel
comes I get in the [ __ ] car pool and I
leave and I go there and I'm always
there I've never been late I never cut
class ever bro I never cut class okay
and so one time my dad wasn't home he
was not working somewhere and another
another state and my mom was she would
even come in she would just be like from
her room Chris you gotta get up never be
like [ __ ] we got mad and she's
like oh yeah and I would just be in bed
be like yeah
and I wasn't and then she was like you
gotta be late everybody so I could even
get back to sleep and so I got up
started the shower and as I was I can't
believe what I did this but I started
the shower as I started the shower I
turned on
the the faucet and as the water came out
I was like I hope the water coming out
is loud enough to drown this out and I
said I think I said [ __ ] you really loud
my mom and I've never said that before
ever and she didn't say anything
I took the shower I got a carpet went to
school and I got home later and I think
my dad was home at that point and my dad
was like I can't do anything for a week
you're grounded
sounds like why he's you [ __ ] you I was
like why did I think I was so tired and
sleepy that I thought the [ __ ] shower
coming out would drown out me screaming
[ __ ] you have done all that's that no no
when you're like I didn't if I had a kid
and they said [ __ ] my mom slow montz
yeah she slapped me once I think I
called her a [ __ ] or so yeah but I was
a little punk and I was like you're a
[ __ ] and she slapped the [ __ ] out of me
is the only time I spoke like that I
knew it the moment the words left my
mouth yeah yeah I know I was like you
bit it started moving in slow-mo she
didn't miss a beat man made that letter
so scary I never even know your dad
would get murdered women would dare
that's like to even try your dad would
bury you
yes Wow can't even think it he wouldn't
know see that's amazing how do you get
that way well you really know yeah yeah
yeah cuz I want to be but I'll tell you
my parents didn't give me too much [ __ ]
they gave me a lot of freedom and I was
always late I skipped class really all
that really but I mean I was fine I got
into college you know that's the thing
though like when I wasn't gonna do it
your own way right when I would have
I knew my boundaries I was late and
tardy and I was 18 so I kept my own oh
right right right I knew the boundaries
I didn't get kicked out or anything yeah
because my when I was my like they would
I totally lost my train of thought my
boundaries I don't know my I don't know
I don't know what else [ __ ] well they
gave me all the freedom they gave me
lots of you
my own day but let me show you this then
okay yeah
close stop coughing stop coughing
I'm sorry that's okay what what this is
a bathroom where the stall is basically
like frosted glass you can see the
silhouette of a dude what it is a black
guy it's way worse because you have the
whole back for his white but also homie
next one with his dick out you could see
no right Wow oh yeah I'm sure I even
think about that yeah did that's so
it'll be funny if there's a glory hole
and you can see the guy's face this is
like the saddest looking [ __ ] is that
dude the world is great there's
everything in the world do you
understand there's this there's
everything I never thought of this
possibly existing yeah I know that's
what I'm saying you even think about
this and it's there do you think this
guy do you think this guy when you went
to [ __ ] on this toilet realize what he
was knowing or did he just have he
didn't really been he realized you know
why because he's faced that way oh my
God he's not faced the right he's
sitting when I went he knows wait he's
in a yes way that way here's the other
thing - yeah I if I walked in and I saw
that and I just [ __ ] I would out loud
say well this what the [ __ ] you're gonna
you're gonna have to see me [ __ ] you
have to see me [ __ ] you gotta say how
does sitting a little in an angle on the
toilet oh yeah she's consciously yeah
yeah and not to say that guy you know
it's funny to like this is expensive to
do comparative yeah that's the rule like
the premium upgrade where do you think
this is I know where this is a hundred
percent there's no way this is not in
the dominican republic manic in reverse
no [ __ ] way first of all I feel
shorts yeah that's a bit minikin
Republican who would drop extra cash on
there no no I won't think dominican
republic would do that to be honest I
was gonna feel like an airport in Miami
yeah cuz it's like funky I could see
that being an airport because they try
to design it's so cruel like you're
already king in an airport which sucks I
did that the other I did that the other
day yeah I've no IV zero qualms about
using going to about them in any
bathroom I don't care [ __ ] II don't care
really do you put the paper down only
when it's completely necessary are
always missus
do not wipe down to see it if there's
yeah yeah I always a little once over
yeah if it looks clean nah oh my
gangster bro that's gangster I'm not I'm
not I know that's a gangster I'm not I'm
not you don't give me extra [ __ ] to do
what I gotta do you know I'm so crazy
about it yeah even if I go to a friend's
house yeah I put that's too much that's
crazy yeah that's yeah you put TP down
mm-hmm yeah I did some research
apparently you can't really contract
anything from a toilet seat yeah also
you're just putting your legs on it it's
just your thighs yeah yeah but also I
don't want a stranger peeing on my
thighs do you know but that's why if
there's piss on it I'll wipe it down you
know but also you want I have a routine
okay I'd like to hear when I go in a
public bathroom so first of all the
toilet seat covers are terrific
first I wipe it down with that because
the toilet paper it absorbs so much
liquid you're gonna get pee in your
hands you have to get a bunch of it yeah
and then when you put it in the water
and then when you put in the water it
dissolves but the trick is you want
enough in the toilet so that when you
[ __ ] it doesn't splash on your ass
because let's face it sitting on an
empty seat may be gangster but getting
water splashed on your ass in a public
toilet seat I don't know what that is
but it's not gangster so you take you
take a bunch to the toilet seat covers
and you put them in the toilet so that
it's questions
Wow driver taking this [ __ ] but I'm
telling you it's you can't do without it
it cushions the [ __ ] and you will never
get splashed so you don't need that many
three four five six seven eight no I'm
kidding not that man just enough to be
wasteful and so you need to create an
inn and then I think that's really
important key you know I put only get
slashed a thing down if it's necessary
if I get splashed I go like this
I I literally go like I literally go
like this I do that and and then my my
dick sometimes hits the the bone I go
what am I gonna do what are we gonna do
oh my god I like that what am I gonna do
and I'm fine and I'm fine
I know I don't I don't have weird
diseases I'm fine and and it sucks
but it's fine and here's the thing I was
I want to go do it I don't know where
the [ __ ] we were my opener never will
never use if he is it he'll he'll be
like oh I guess I'm gonna [ __ ] my pants
you know I'm like a crazy boy what a
toilet is there I don't care right yeah
so so I went and I was waiting because
there was a line and this guy I counted
flushed 13 times before me and I don't
know what the [ __ ] he was doing cuz
standing up he was standing up oh yeah
so he was done and I was just [ __ ]
gay okay what here's the other thing too
I can't stand when when you're in the
bathroom and you're doing whatever you
got to do in there
mm-hm and someone and and it once is
fine because they don't know if it and
then again [ __ ] bathroom as long as
I need to
I walked out once I walked out once she
I opened up the door and there was a
lady and I said hey what you think I'm
doing and maybe I don't know one time
this is great how's that a coffee bean
and I was and I was doing it I was going
to bathroom number two did that's brave
bro at a coffee bean my tea I don't
think I could do that unless I was
having diarrhea yeah I even kind to have
to go yeah yeah yeah I know I'm serious
doing what I do
think that if you could get past the
stigma it would be very freeing it is
dropping really anyway when I come here
do I give you not good do I not give a
good [ __ ] advice you do good you
know the Metamucil changed my life
yeah the metaphor sounds amazing all
right well you you have a good track
rack so so so so so I was doing this in
the coffee bean and and the handle of
the coffee bean I know here's how
gangster I am by the way
it's broken well it's it's broken and I
know it's broken and here on yellow
there's a lock but I know you can open
it anyway okay so it's like a fit it's
not a good so so I this is how I think
this is how I think in my brain oh this
is the kind of guy I am
in all honesty I think ok it's broken I
have to take a [ __ ] [ __ ] you coffee bean
this is how we're doing it okay I'm
gonna do it if someone walks in I will
not be embarrassed because you don't
imagine it someone's box at Chris D'Elia
[Laughter]
so I'm like all right coughing this is a
gimme 104 complaint that people don't
see me [ __ ] in your staff they gotta fix
that this is a people can see me [ __ ] in
your establishment okay and and you're
gonna deal with it because I'm not I am
NOT if you know what it's like it's like
when somebody goes when somebody goes to
you
hey what's up good to see you hey you
don't remember my name huh you trying to
make me feel awkward I [ __ ] look at
you and I say no yeah no dude I don't
remember you you're not gonna [ __ ]
make me feel bad about this [ __ ] okay
you be more memorable right so I'm
taking this [ __ ] the locks wrong and I'm
just waiting dude I'm not gonna do I'm
not gonna do it any longer than I need
to but I'm sitting I'm waiting and all
of a sudden King King and I'm like all
right here we go all right well that
person just realize this locks with
someone's in here obviously okay then
again good good good and I'm like all
right oh hey dude all right I I mean
you're as long as a [ __ ] it's locked
obviously third time could go and I'm
like and I'm and I sit up and I wait and
I head up and there's no stall or
anything it's just and I'm
at the door and I'm not [ __ ] you
know and I'm waiting do tonight and I
can't wait to I can't wait and I can't
wait to and I'm all perched up and I'm
and I'm waiting kicking kicking and it
opens it breaks and they open it up bro
she's 12
oh no that was my mine mine the
worst-case scenario she's a 12 year old
girl yeah and I'm sitting there and I go
that was fine no I wanted it to be a 45
year old white male or some [ __ ] yeah
that's the worst you know in this case I
have in my head the whole plan of how
I'm gonna catch the door well just panic
of it no no because I'm so paranoid that
someone will see me yeah in there that I
have to like I even like almost like
practice in my head then oh like that
come here like what could I possibly be
doing there bro one time one time I had
to go so bad this is at the counter
there's a burger place over the fact of
this guy's you know you can't read his
face we could see shame yeah so one time
I had to go to the counter I don't mean
to monopolize the [ __ ] stories but
I've had nothing oh here's the other
thing I do too here's the other thing I
do too if there's a man if there's a man
a I'm a male and then a female and the
male's locked and the females open I
identify as a female I go in I don't get
[ __ ] I don't care I don't care I'm with
you so I go in but I walk in and it's
it's one with stalls and and and things
and it's like a multiple one on my car
great if I can't lock it but I am in
trouble
I have to go feels like there's nothing
I could do I have to go in the female
one
I'm gonna go in the stall I'm gonna hide
you know I'm not gonna look obviously
I'm just I just I need to get my
business done so I'm there and the door
opens
and I'm like well of course it's a
female mmm like [ __ ] and she says
hey did anyone see a guy come in here
and I'm like I'm like thank God I'm
already on the toilet because I would
have [ __ ] my pants on my own no cuz I
know I'm doing I'm doing something
that's not on my coat I'm doing
something wrong I feel bad right I don't
want to be a perv but I had to go so bad
right so and then I'm like what I was
like should I go should I go in my head
I'm like should I go what but I'm like
that's ridiculous you know I just said
what she walks a little further and I
see her and then I see you know how like
when the door closes there's like that
much yeah yeah dude I make straight-up
high contact with her with one eye and
she's looking at and she says so I say
what she says did anyone see an iPhone
in here and I swear to God I misheard
her wait why she looking for your song
and I looked at her and I said I said no
I thought you said did anyone see a guy
come in here and she said I thought you
know I have a [ __ ] story that sticks out
to me at this office oh really
I'm in there taking a dump I should here
all the time but I have a bucket of baby
wipes that I actually take with me to
the bathroom enough and so I'm doing
that I'm taking care of my vid like to
take my time on the John I mean to make
sure it's all clean and good to go
even with Metamucil it hasn't been set
the aid to me I still wipe yeah
sometimes more than others yeah I'm in
the bathroom I'm taking [ __ ] I'm doing
my business so two older gentlemen walk
in and they're talking about golf and
you know whatever old people talk about
you know
one guy goes to take a piss one guy goes
to take a [ __ ] they're talking about
golf the conversation doesn't miss a
beat first of all the guys taking a math
like a really noisy [ __ ] blocks the gas
just blowing ass and I'm in there kind
of giggling because he's just he doesn't
miss a beat with his homie
nobody acknowledges that the dude is
blowing chunks
I don't like trumpeting and they don't
miss a beat now here's where it gets
interesting dude from the urinal is done
and dude in the [ __ ] is done at the
same time
no wiping no nothing in there
the dude blasted ass a crazy [ __ ] and
was done at the same time as his home
who was peeing homie who was peeing goes
and washes hands and the homie who [ __ ]
walks out with the guy who peed without
washing his hands and I'm in there
horrified like listening like daredevil
with my Doppler hearing but understand
you can understand so he blasted ass
didn't miss a beat didn't wash his hands
and [ __ ] and exited the bathroom quicker
even because he didn't wash in the same
time as his homie peed without missing a
beat of the conversation and his friend
didn't say [ __ ] he's you know what I'm
saying very weird that's like the
beginning of an x-files show you're like
how did this happen yeah cue the music
you need to get mold or what that's
weird but like these guys I mean how do
you continue even being friends with
somebody after that the only way I can
continue beef no white buddy after that
is okay we're like so like yeah I don't
wipe [ __ ] that [ __ ]
I'll be like woah alright I got a
[ __ ] chill with this guy yeah but
then you've got me but this save this
day yeah I mean you get [ __ ] on your
hands sometimes it happens well no let
me tell you something some we all have
[ __ ] on our hand right now
okay boys you know and stop with this
stop with this bat stop trying to do
sometimes you get [ __ ] on your hand
I understand but shits the clunkers [ __ ]
like a chocolate yeah he didn't even
wife
well that's true well that's a fair
point well he didn't look that's kind of
an interesting thing he's like look I'd
rather have it on my ass hold my hands
cause it's gross but then you get all
itchy oh no it's like you've got a white
dude yeah you got away you cannot wipe
even if it's a clean one you got away
and then his age and the way he blasted
ask me blackballed did you can't even
move mobility issue he just comes home
with the shitty ass I guess it could
happen at a certain age where you're
like [ __ ] it I'm gonna die in probably
five years I'm not wasting my precious
moments on this earth wiping my ass [ __ ]
that's it there you go
see that's gangster Chris if you want to
know what gangsters in the bathroom it's
not wiping your ass or cleaning your
hand I agree with dr. okay well we got
more stuff to watch here you I know have
been taking on tick tock
oh man and I've got some great tick tock
so I want to watch it's so funny that
app like it's so some of that well all
of them really are so bad well Christina
yeah has been she just wrote me she was
like yeah I want to get you on and talk
about tick tock what uh what does she do
I didn't know I don't know he just
reposts on Instagram really cringey ones
but she finds ones like really crazy
really old people yeah you notice that
yeah I saw some like and these are all
people that probably don't even know how
to use their email right and how the
[ __ ] are they managing it tick tock I
don't know it's hard for me to do I was
like I did exactly yeah so it's a whole
phenomenon I and I will and I feel bad
saying goodbye to our shooting friend
here but it's time to X him out and
bring up the tick tock how did you
discover tick tock you spend a lot of
time on there I I would see it on
Instagram and I feel like what the [ __ ]
is this just I would I would be like it
was like the crowning moment of the apps
where it went too far on the frame
I was like like like even vine when I
did vine it was like I felt like I was
making fun of vine when I was doing mine
but there's no but
tick-tock there's no self-aware there's
no self-awareness right people are just
like doing [ __ ] like like like guys yeah
I mean like they're doing like growls
like real growls that's perfect yeah I
don't understand the phenomena and I and
I feel like tick tock is its own
self-contained community like people on
tick tock don't know anyone on YouTube
for exams and well well that's
definitely true but like I don't know I
I guess I maybe it's one of those things
where I'm officially old because I just
make sure you re I got to pause the
music cuz if I play this our whole
podcast will get claimed oh okay then
what do you do so I'm just gonna mute
the music and oh it's all really generic
stupid [ __ ] you get you off or you
say no no it's it's okay it's just I
feel like I'm cause I don't I don't get
it I don't get I I don't get I don't
like these people are gonna grow up
right and still and see this and be like
oh god what do you think about that like
I'm so thankful that the internet wasn't
around when I was a kid I think we
probably we're almost the same age I
feel like we I think I feel like the
first iPhone came out when I was in
college yeah we hold you I just turned
34
oh so you're nine so yeah I think I'm
lucky when I would like any later or or
you know like better than that really
maybe like late 20s is okay but like
there's if you're 20 now you you have
some [ __ ] on oh yeah because
everything you do back then is
embarrassed yeah save that for life so
here is these are some deep cuts like
kind of in the vein of what I was
talking about so this is a woman holding
a box filled with her husband's ashes on
tik-tok and doing a song and it's
something like uh
jump to something about how and God see
I can't play the music she's dancing to
them to the song but it's our husband's
cremated ashes oh my god but she's got
some slick zooms and edits and I just
don't understand how they'd figure it
out yeah oh wait so does she or is it
part of that I actually have never used
you know I don't know I've only don't
like four of them you're so pretty crazy
I don't do that automatic so it's
something like you can shoot it to where
they stay slow down the song so when
you're recording it you're doing it slow
that's how they get that that's not
that's honestly how they do a lot of the
the Eminem videos they would all be like
did what I did and the old ones you know
how he's always like yeah that's how
they get that and Hornby's do it too
whether people are let you don't I mean
did they play the song for you slowed
yeah really yeah because that's how they
make that so I must feel really awkward
when you're doing it so yeah first time
yeah but uh so they so that's what that
is but then you can go in afterwards and
like put effects in okay um I don't know
if you can zoom afterwards or what like
I don't know how she's doing it there
must be like a I think there's a
hands-free mode or I don't know how you
cut it after that he's a high-level tape
talker really and so this is her with
her husband's ashes
oh we give love and whatever however you
grieve I guess and so here's one see
this one I really wish I had the music
my favorite ones are the ones of the
guys that think they're sexy there
aren't any better than that when the
guys in their place like furries and
[ __ ] you know yeah yeah yeah you know I
mean would they do lip stuff so there's
actually a whole sub-genre of tick-tocks
of divorced
tic TOCs there's like divorced on us a
divorce yes what does that mean well
here I'll give you an example like
here's a dude a cop who's on duty by the
way this guy's sworn to protect and
serve and homie is making a tik-tok with
a rain cloud over his wedding band how
many times can I forgive the cheating
this is the fourth and he taped there's
there's you know like badass country
music playing and he takes off his
wedding band
epic you know what
MLG Edith so that's why [ __ ] promise
you there's a honor them and there he's
not he's not taking the piss he's not
joking no this guy's for real I swear to
you I cop I know man did if anyone ever
like if you ever run across like blue
lives matter people like oh called you
know show him this do you know what
happens after you make this video you
know what happens the fifth time that's
right
that's all you that's who gets cheated
on yeah she was cheating on him because
he would be the guy who does that right
that's true I mean that's that's
self-fulfilling there's so many of them
but they're all kind of had a whole list
but it gets repetitive but it's just a
bunch of dudes taking off their wedding
band and being music I swear all right
well let's all look up a bunch let me
pull up cuz I want to prove it yeah yeah
hold on it's in it's in your document
right damn
yeah there's a whole thing with her
thread about the divorce ticks up right
here and it was the first time I felt
like wow I'm getting old yeah yeah yeah
you're younger than I how old are you
I'm 31
oh yeah yeah and I because I just feel
so out of it I have no idea what's going
on I mean do they make me let when I do
up to them we're making fun of it man I
it's for me dude I laugh so hard at the
[ __ ]
you
playing it there you go are we good do
you have a way of muting the sound
without muting us I can't hear that Dan
can I hear you know yeah okay hold down
your laptop okay here you know yeah wait
so wait I can only mute it on my laptop
no we muted it back here okay [ __ ] I
love that you play to seven two seconds
yes and they claimed the whole [ __ ]
to our podcast but here so this person
wild milk basically made a whole right
up these are all on ironic tick-tock so
just to kind of show your honor okay oh
come on Dan what's going on here I'm
trying to run a business
we have it all turned down back here I
don't know man just hit me but wait now
your video you have where's the sound
coming from
I'm here because it always plays it
though all right homie just um G just
made a couple thousand bucks but you got
a little taste of the music yeah so
that's why I mean but they get real
repetitive I know but I'd still like to
see every single one okay like this
guy's got it man
he showed a picture of him and his wife
he flip oh wow got it man that's [ __ ]
bro that's sad on so many levels
oh well this is well this one is just
straight-up pathetic hold on hold on
what's what you say
Danna I don't know what to do how do i
how do i fix this issue very [ __ ]
together your funnel gets divorced yeah
but I've been to boycott of yours
I can't mute it you're right there yeah
but but then when you go to the next one
it's not muted and if I turn this down I
can't hear Dan yeah just turn it down
for now
I can't you keep your being but see if I
turn this down does the audience still
hear it though just just Mewtwo each one
just meet each 100
when you mute okay yeah all right I
divorced so this guy's been divorced for
five thirteen years of marriage twenty
seven years together three wonderful
kids divorced almost five years now this
is a tick tock a public tick tock and he
opens the card my heart still only sees
you it was like the most ghetto look at
this is bar forgets me that's the part
that really gets me oh my god and that's
sad and that's what music playing yeah I
see okay if I don't touch it oh okay
then I guess the sound will play but
it's you're almost doomed because you
don't have a chance to unmute it put
both oh it's just an empty house she
moved out but there's like triumphant
music playing oh this one's got divorce
papers with their wedding bands without
the divorce filing come on with her
rings on it and hearts the music really
adds the loss will flip the pages
quicker Oh black and white of course so
uh look at that guy he's taking his ring
off yeah I'm free today hoping that like
their next love your wife will see this
and feel bad for them because it's like
Chris said there's a lot of dudes who
are I don't know why because I would
assume there's just a little girl so
unless these guys are trying to [ __ ]
little girls I don't really understand
the vibe I mean look there's [ __ ] 19
million people who follow tick-tock on
Instagram well if 19 million people are
falling tick-tock on Instagram it's not
yeah so anyway you get the ideas but I
don't what is that what is on the right
Oh what the [ __ ] oh yeah you can do this
- I don't know about it but oh he's
proposed rising on tick tock tick tock
you guys why are you so involved with
tick tock I swear to god that guy
doesn't know how to check his [ __ ]
Matt AOL dot-com email address
Wow oh yeah so this guy's proposing on a
split screen tick-tock
Wow man who could predict little
grandmas down you see that made you see
that you know [ __ ] them
they've been down a lot lately gotta get
their [ __ ] together mmm but I've got
more it gets better
I'm going down the depressing rabbit
hole no oh speaking of guys being sexy
here's one that I that I think you'll
really enjoy
okay so there's like really bad it's
like it says fat gross fat gross that
Dom he's getting blasted it goes with
the mean oh yeah he's getting shot oh
really you think I'm ugly well [ __ ] you
[ __ ] oh yeah that's that's a that's a
very good I know though I know that so
he ended up put his hand to the camera
and then when he took it away he looked
like a ha seed with a fedora it looks
like good character see if I play it
it's gonna play sound oh no it's muted
what's the movie that I just saw her he
looks like the guy he's getting blasted
really [ __ ] you haven't seen me in my
the bearded chub yeah I did want it I
did I got to do one of those tic TOCs I
got it do one of those two key on it see
I don't want to have to dress up in [ __ ]
it's okay this is my all-time favorite
tick-tock and it's not funny oh and
there's no music
okay I mean it's got a it's got all the
twists and turns you would expect from
great literature to be honest so why do
I have not have sound now hold on let me
unmute everything so why is that Wow
yeah and why do I even wonder what's
going on
tick tock is here to ruin my life okay
so am I supposed to have sound and know
my shits hold on we're all turned up
back here you sure that video has audio
what is going on yeah it definitely has
audio I mean she's talking me lips are
moving I've watched it before
so what happened why did the audio just
come back on
we just ran through everything again
okay one hi there I know this is not
interesting but it's it's fun for me um
you guys know how I wear my hair I might
look like Little Orphan Annie by the
time this is all done but I wanted to
give it a try my tactic I think these
might be too big for on top wow it's
almost dry anyhow if it doesn't work I
could just wash it out and try turning
curlers another way anyhow this is fun
for me it doesn't take much for me to
have fun with myself and I wish there
was people here I would have my husband
do something for lunch I would take you
all out to lunch and we would just laugh
and have a great time anyhow I'll see if
I could save this no I'm not gonna save
it to a draft oh I would just maybe I
don't try okay
oh my god why not like these singles a
tragic video however yeah yeah Wow
that's odd huh I'm laughing just because
you know how to process yes it's a lot
because I was what I was watching that
at him at first time yeah but then it's
go so sad then I see the thing that was
tweeting the other day that was kind of
it was on yesterday it was uh the game
show Beat Shazam and the thing that and
the thing I had that and the guy at the
end wait
you know I literally have that I was
just looking at Shazam where is that
here it is
[ __ ] yellow did you see this yeah you
saw this from your oh okay
I watched the whole end and I was like
yeah this is okay but you might want to
put the beginning because the music
but does it matter if it's what is going
on with this club man okay I think we're
good here I don't know where that music
came from from the very beginning it's
it's from a commercial yeah you gotta
watch till the end for this guy I don't
know the premise of this game show but
I'm assuming is this song before Shazam
congestus song Oh whoo Shazam a robot oh
it's an ass is sponsored by Shazam oh
that's pretty good it's not a fun
contest yes my first heard it I don't
know I would be very bad at this game
so homie just one 206 right now he
that's how a huge come on so you saw
this right see I saw and I wash all the
ways and wondering what the [ __ ] yeah
what's going on here thank you this is
such a twist man
we won the game shows over everyone's
happy right at the ending super app they
trap you in a storybook and then
well they got ya so close credit
dedication how do you dedicate his own
episode to him mo just just don't tell
us he died or don't air the episode
right right well it's not I think he
aired it's nice cuz he crushed it under
a she just say we didn't have to pay him
oh that mmm do you think they paid his
his family I guess brawling probably
yeah I love that they dedicated his own
episode to him mm-hmm that's like the
cut you know dedicating this podcast to
me if you die on your way home or even
now it's like obviously it's dedicated
to you you know you can't dedicate we
dedicate the crystal the episode to
crystal you know by its dedicated yeah
yeah that was great
why does what all the game shows
happening lately so many I don't know I
well there was a boom when like Who
Wants to Be a Millionaire started and
then I don't know I just kind of kept
going and go on I've done a few recently
oh you've been on yeah I didn't there
yet I did the Anthony Anderson one and I
did the other one did you crush I don't
know no I didn't do well on the Anthony
Anderson one and then I did another one
were you playing for money or charity I
never played for money I must've been
charity or oh you know you know what I
did I was like - they have like
celebrity judges or like helpers or
something I did one with what was the
one Alec Baldwin alright I haven't
watched that but I've seen the thumbnail
whatever it is called I did that that's
cool
like Alec yeah that's good at that I've
noticed that on game shows there's a
pyramid dan says that it no that's not
it but what one of them was called to
tell the truth I think that's Andy
Anthony Anderson one there's this new
thing like there's this show where
they'll have a celebrity pop in who has
nothing to do with it like what's the
one with uh you know I didn't know what
I'm talking about let's move on all
right okay I get it man you know
sometimes you just like what the [ __ ]
[Music]
[Laughter]
it's been an hour and a half it asked
Jesus all right I have a lot more so
it's really up to you I mean we got [ __ ]
two more two more yeah cuz I've got have
you been following a J on Twitter hello
to the world
hello it's yours truly a weirdo he don't
believe anyone Wow
alright for the world the crazy the
crazy thing about og is that like he's
always golfing he's always on vacation
he's always got a cigar like he didn't
murder two people that like he's still
just an anomaly and he's living the life
he posted one recently that I thought
was pretty good we can watch together
yeah he goes never too old to learn he's
always like on a 90s sitcom set and he
always recorded like hey it's me Oh Jay
the world this is me yours truly you
know in the last 48 hours I've learned
that you're never too old to learn two
days ago was my birthday and I got
hacked at my computer well I probably
got more dope than that if somebody was
setting the knife emojis through my DM
fortunately for me my bank alerted me
that there was a charge to coming in
from Europe in Euros and they didn't get
imagine being that employee at the bank
hi is this Oh Jay simply didn't lose
anything except some time and stuff but
the problem was I was travelling the
next day which was yesterday
and I had to get some cash for my
friends I think I was in good shape
companies in America that will not
the American dollar for goods or
services really I mean at one point I
couldn't even buy a bottle of water you
know III just thought well when did the
American dollar get usurped I grew up
they said cash was king I guess not has
been relegated to a Duke or an earl in
any event I know there's a lot of
Americans that don't have credit cards
and right now just throwing the role Jay
stabbed you help me make a
jack-o-lantern could you teach me how to
deal with an ungrateful wife who's
cheating on me did anyone else notice
how he starts off with a little laugh
like watch this well will you be
murdering any more people in cold blood
I mean it's it's great it doesn't
disappoint you live like that well you
killed look at that one that's funny
click on that one how to get away with
murder oh wow that's awesome hey OH J my
girlfriend I are having some
relationship problems got any advice on
how to deal with her yeah it's oh [ __ ]
let's not show that [ __ ] me why is that
not censored out mm-hmm
YouTube's like or Twitter hate Twitter
water don't care whoopsie-daisy let me
know if he you got to take on let's see
we got Oh Jay we got our Kelly goes to
prison for sex trafficking okay wait he
did oh well he's being trialed oh yeah
yeah have you seen their haven't you
have your passports clip oh you talked
about yeah yeah so he's getting his
passports revoked oh so he does not he
no longer has his passports there you
know they are using probably this song
is proof yeah they may show that in
court
I don't judge the judge like mr. Kelly
can you explain this yeah
do you have your passport
we are revoking your passport Jason
Momoa said he says name the god Bob body
shames I tweeted that I went yeah nuts
but yeah that's not a dead body
he's jacked yeah let me let me post this
picture this is the picture you know I
don't know if you follow this people
were saying that he's let himself go do
you have any concept like he is fully
jacked he would crush my skull with his
hand you know people are clowning on him
like oh where'd your six-pack go dude
someone's got their dad working on their
dad bod it's like he will [ __ ] you
know that's not a that's not a dad bod
that's just kind of a good bod yeah yeah
I mean he so the difference is is that
he I think on set you do all this crazy
work right I get you all the blind he
was very very shredded an Aquaman yeah
so he probably is all dehydrated and
does all this crazy [ __ ] but he's just
as jacked big yeah he's big yeah what
did you say on Twitter on Twitter world
I said something like I can't remember
bro he would steal all your girls he'll
literally steal you too he [ __ ] you he
would make love to you and you're
straight
[ __ ] off with that dadbod shed my
brother said my body is better period
end of sentence under tweet right there
look what does he do I didn't know you
had a brother
yeah he's a director I'm gonna write him
he's a cowboy yeah he's a cowboy he's
just kind of actually his Park House
just came out yesterday oh good yeah
what's it called
Matthew Lee is confused well there you
have it have a listen Scarlett you know
this is all a bunch of [ __ ]
we're done okay [ __ ] a long time blue
by oh actually I do have the the bagel
boss oh yeah I have a there's like a
whole
ongoing saga with her it's weird to me
what goes real viral and what doesn't
like that was like dumb but the fact
that that was viral for more than a day
shocks me I think it's because they're
keping developments oh they kept finding
them on the street and you would say
more such a little character dude he
definitely is like he's been on Howard
Stern he's gonna join the whack pack was
that oh you don't listen to Howard Stern
I guess he's got like a little pack of
weirdos but I love I mean the country
it's so good daddy issues for sure the
guy next to him is only five foot eight
but the guy why did the skirt yeah it's
so over-the-top I mean he's so low that
this guy had like the one chance in his
life to feel like a badass well if I was
gonna fight anyone I would fight him cuz
I'm like odds are in my favor
yeah but this guy like one guy laughs
laughs everyone's having a good time
yeah he wasn't gonna do anything what do
you thought this guy was a threat this
guy got all courageous he's like I can
take this floor blind al
I love it and then the bagel guy got in
he was like if you come into the bagel
store mention this you get a free bagel
yeah but I heard that was [ __ ] no
there's a tweet right there oh really oh
oh if you mention it if you come in and
mention oh wow that you saw the video
you get a free bagel there's a second
video here if you want to know what
happened next
I know if you saw this I did yeah so he
got back up I love that he got back up
and kept going fantastic
powerful okay bagel boss yeah once you
do make this easy let me do that
I'm clicking you can hear okay maybe
it's a sign
yeah yeah yeah he got back up well dude
when you know if it's a not how hard you
fall down is how could you get right oh
he was hungry too you can see here
because he throws the bagel at him and
then he goes back and picks it up I
wonder what happened he went home and
ate a bagel no before nothing the girl
was laughing at him it seems like and he
took it the wrong way
[Music]
this guy just wants to nut he is very
sure you know some chick probably said
shrimp look it's probably tough to be
that height yeah oh yeah honestly don't
but he is being [ __ ] [ __ ] of
course I mean maybe not gonna increase
his chances of yeah yeah yeah yeah well
he actually know that he's virally
probably he thinks someone's gonna [ __ ]
him now definitely good for him you know
but my favorite part of this is that he
throws the bagel and there's like
actually I went to bed I go back and get
the bagel there was no resolution not on
Adebayo yeah if this goes on and I
that's about it you know we had a good
run here we cover a lot of ground good
we discussed a lot of things favored for
coming yeah I know you're busy gotta
move now
this guy's gonna be worth 100 million
dollars okay go to crystal e.com / tour
get some tickets keep your eyes on
Netflix because we got a new special
coming out and a new movie coming out
and what's the title of the movie does
that public army over the Dead army of
the Dead Wow exciting times cool good
times to be Chris D'Elia keep your eyes
out yeah thanks guys
thank you guys for watching we will be
back this Friday with another episode
you will not want to miss this one thank
you to all my food / troopers out there
and shout out to um G who's gonna claim
this full podcast for for two seconds
and accidentally played music so thank
you everybody
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Music]